[Music]
this hospital in the colombian coastal
town tumaco
wasn't prepared for the pandemic the
intensive care unit was only built after
covert 19 had reached the city
and infected thousands
far from the capital bogota the
population here has never been the focus
of government decisions
now it's paying for the lack of health
infrastructure
like many other remote parts of the
country
the coronavirus is riskier for
indigenous communities
lack of health services and clean water
poverty
keeping variants out of rural canada has
been difficult
but adults in remote parts are getting
priority access to the vaccine
aboriginal and torres strait islander
people prevented widespread infections
in australia with their own travel
restrictions
their vaccine rollout is getting
underway indigenous groups are also
among the first to be getting the jab in
new zealand the us
canada and brazil but things don't look
so good in colombia
andres rojas has been working for a year
in the intensive care unit
of the saint andrews hospital in tumaco
it's the only hospital in the far
southwest of colombia
a year ago the clinic didn't have any
intensive care bids
things changed quickly when the covet-19
pandemic began
at the start of the first outbreak we
had more than 2500 patients
21 of them died and 17 were transferred
to another hospital
hospital is one of many provincial
clinics in colombia
that opened up intensive care units for
the first time during the pandemic
it was only after the pandemic hit that
we could even think about setting up an
intensive care station
at the moment it provides 13 units with
monitors breathing devices
electric beds and staff who we trained
ourselves
according to dr rojas some funding came
from the government
but most of it came from private
initiatives local businesses were
especially generous with their donations
tomoko is dependent on the tourist
industry
this is an advertisement from better
times the location is the pacific coast
next to ecuador's border around 1 000
kilometers
from the capital of bogota tourists come
here from around the world
despite the location's popularity
medical infrastructure was largely
ignored by politicians in the capital of
bogota
before the hospital had 38 oxygen tanks
imagine that trying to get through a
pandemic with 38 tanks of oxygen
thanks to donations from local business
totaling 400 000 pesos
we could set up the hospital with a
liquid oxygen tank
this helps a little but the second wave
of infections is now bringing a shortage
of medicine
no one here can think about vaccines
against covet 19
the staff are approaching burnout
you can feel their tiredness some staff
members have fainted from exhaustion
their working hours are very very long
at the beginning of march 117 000
vaccine doses were delivered to bogota
these were meant to reach 50 million
colombians
but nobody in tumaco believes that they
will get a single dose
juan mario diaz is a research fellow in
the department of politics and
international relations at the
university of sheffield
why is the situation so difficult in
some of colombia's marginalized
communities
well to understand the situation of
these marginalized communities it's
important to
take into consideration what former
government called
the historical depth of colombian state
with
rural areas which basically can be
summarized in four aspects the first one
is the
the development gap which refers to
rural areas not having basic services
like water electricity roads hospitals
or schools the second refers to a
social inequality and lung concentration
according to oxfam
uh 66 percent of productive life
la land in colombia is in the hands of
0.4 percent of the total population
the third one is the problem of the lack
of states presence in some areas as
some of them are still under control of
illegal groups and the fourth
perhaps the most worrying is the que
the victims of the question the question
victim sorry
which according to the 2013 report of
the center
of historical memory indicates that
more than 200 000 people were killed in
the last 15 years
and more than 5 million of colombians
were displaced
from rural areas so this is a a picture
that
indicates why the situation is so
complicated for this
communities juan mario can you tell me
what happened to the peace process
surely that has improved the situation
in some way
well the peace process is an important
landmark in colombia history
uh initially was portrayed as as a way
of
bringing to an end 50 years of war uh
which was a narrative that really
strongly appealed to the international
community and this is why the
this process was surrounded by the
international organizations
but what what is interesting is what
happened in colombia during
the four years that the conversations in
havana
occurred a series of national
and regional forums were convened by the
negotiating parties which allow people
to discuss
the points of the peace agenda basically
people get involved in discussing
agrarian reform political participation
the question of victims
uh transitional justice and the
substitution of
illegal crops which gave us the sense
as a as a colombians that the peace
process was a great opportunity to
transform
peacefully all of these social problems
that we have historically had in the
country
so that'll bring a lot of hope but at
the same time the
the the no referendum the victory
the victory of the no camp of the
referendum plus the lack of
implementation of the process is a
matter of concern as
we see all the high hopes of the
national population being
met with um with no compliance
and delusion okay so many social
problems remain
especially for afro-colombian groups i
believe how is the pandemic affecting
their situation
uh i think the pandemia has just made
more apparent
a structural problems in the pacific
coast
and in some rural areas
just to give you an idea just before the
pandemia
40 of public hospitals were closed
and and so the former government
declared a state of social emergency
when the vadim came uh hospitals in
rural areas were completely unprepared
to deal with that
and well basically the lack of resources
and the lack of
agency from some uh communities were
just uh
something that they really struggled to
to deal with
but what is more concerning for for
these communities
is not just the virus but also the
re-emergence of violence
which allow us to see the whole
situation of a syndemia which is the
combination of
the pandemia plus structural elements
that
impinge on a
bringing solutions to people and to
dealing with the problem effectively
so what's the best way to tackle the big
divide in colombia and ensure these
people get treated or vaccinated
uh i think the first thing we need to
think about
is how to de-politicize the
the way that anemia is addressing the
country we cannot think this is a
political problem but as a social
problem
as a health problem so i think the
government need to
listen as well more what people is
saying from the territory from
what the local uh the local
administrations are
these messages that the local
administrations are sending to the to
the local
to the central government in order to
get better results in the way that
colombia is dealing with this okay we'll
have to leave it there juan mahario diaz
thank you very much for being on the
show today
thank you very much if you've got a
question about the coronavirus feel free
to get in contact with our science
correspondent
derek williams
if you are asymptomatic and don't know
you have copied 19
is it dangerous to be vaccinated
the short answer to this appears to be
no
but it's a pretty complicated question
so of course
there's a little more to it than that um
current advice
from the u.s centers for disease control
focuses mostly
on whether or not people who've had the
disease and recovered
can be safely vaccinated afterwards the
answer to that
is a clear yes however the cdc
is far less clear about people who might
have an active asymptomatic infection at
the moment they get a shot
the implication though is certainly that
there's no reason to think
that vaccination would pose a danger
that's because the guidelines do say
there's no need to test negative for
infection
before you're vaccinated they also say
that even if you've been exposed
and have been tested and are awaiting
results if you live somewhere
like a rest home you should go ahead and
be vaccinated as long as you don't have
any symptoms i'm sure the guidelines
wouldn't say either one of those things
if there were suspected dangers
for people with asymptomatic infections
being
given the shot and that the cdc would
adopt a much more
cautious approach but it's important
also to remember something else at the
same time
if you know you've been exposed and are
in quarantine
but aren't showing any symptoms don't go
get vaccinated
until your quarantine period has passed
because
you might be an asymptomatic carrier and
even though we've established the
vaccine doesn't pose a threat to you in
that case
you could still pose a potential threat
to people who are vaccinating you
so wait out your couple of weeks just in
case
to protect them
and just briefly the world health
organization says the astrazeneca
vaccine rollout should continue for now
some countries have stopped it over
reports of blood clots
finally we leave you with images from
sao paulo brazil's biggest city
now more of a ghost town the usually
bustling mega city of
21 million people went into curfew this
week to try to stop the coronavirus from
spreading
several brazilian cities running out of
hospital beds as cases
rise and the crisis worsens
thanks for watching
you